nearly two months after a 31 year old
was killed in a motorcycle crash his
mother is speaking out hoping for change
yes joshua aquino died on the 12th of
march after colliding with a car on
spring mountain near jones sasha loftis
joins us live in that area with more and
his family's efforts to keep others safe
brian and denise this memorial just feet
from where josh died here on spring
mountain shows just how much he still
loved but his family believes this road
is still too dangerous and they want to
see something change
he was full of life he was always given
stacey aquino remembers everything she
loved about her son joshua he told me
mom if i pass on the motorcycle i pass
happy and that's what i hold on to the
31 year old's life was cut short in
march
when police say he collided with a car
pulling out of this shopping center on
spring mountain near jones while riding
his motorcycle just those little things
that you don't look as it's important
back then but realize how important it
is now though the pain of this kind of
loss is still overwhelming
stacy wants to stop something like this
from happening again
even though this sign says right turn
only aquino tells us she sees cars
illegally turn left here all the time
and cut over this red median to cause a
hazard if i can help save someone else's
life that's what i want to do this
family that's still dealing with so much
grief would like to see a more visible
sign and stronger traffic control
but more than anything they want other
drivers to follow the rules of the road
your time is precious but there's his
pressures as well and know exactly
what's at stake he was a special one he
was his brothers and sister missed him
dearly
[Music]
stacy mentioned that she would love to
see this sign here moved from behind
that tree so it's a little more visible
to drivers i did reach out to the county
to see if this is possible they asked me
for a photo of the area so they could
look into it reporting live tonight
sasha loftis live local now